Okay.
Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 15th,
2018 what's going on?
How are you?
Um,
I'm in San Francisco.
It's still Sunday.
Uh,
the second half has just begun.
The saints go marching in versus the a Minnesota Vikings.
This saints was my pick this weekend.
I loved drew Brees going into Minnesota and fucking having everybody crying at
the fucking mall of America by the end of the game.
And so far the vikings are up 17 did nothing.
Although I think they just fucking went three and out.
Oh,
case Kate just get put down on his fucking Keester.
MMM.
We'll see.
You never know what's going to happen,
you know.
I mean,
look,
look at the fucking Jaguar's.
The Jaguar's when just came right out,
gave this stale is the old right there.
Fred,
all of a sudden they're running back twists his ankle.
Right?
I don't fear,
I can't put any weight on it,
man.
Right?
Then all of a sudden the Steelers come roaring fucking back and I'm sitting
there going,
this game's over
the Pittsburgh Steelers.
It's in Pittsburgh.
This shit is over.
No Way.
Uh,
what the fuck's his named Bryce portals?
I can't,
by the way,
I can't keep up with these fucking names from the 90s okay.
The cases,
the Bryce,
the Boltons,
the fucking,
I don't know.
You know,
a lot of comics had done bits about it,
but you know,
back when it was like,
you know,
Bill Bob fucking Steve Joe,
yeah.
Greatest quarterback of all fucking time at one point was named Joe.
You know,
Joe Nemeth,
Joe Montana,
Joe Theismann,
Joe
fucking Blake Bortles,
I,
you know,
whatever.
I'm just,
I'm an old,
crabby fucking man.
I guess the nineties it was really big to name your kid after a CNA,
considering all the quarterbacks.
Right.
Kurt Carson case.
Okay.
It's like,
did Roger Clemens Fuck all these women?
Yeah,
but he did that.
It had like fucking nine kids and he,
Cody,
Kyle,
Cunty,
Chris,
right?
They're all case.
They were all Kay's.
Yeah.
Why would you have them have their own identity?
Let's fucking have their name be about your fucking career.
Um,
what do you mean you want to be a veterinarian?
Get the fuck out there.
Pick up a baseball and throw some hay.
MMM,
sorry.
That was my impression of what it's like inside their households.
Like I have any idea.
All right.
I have nothing against the Clemens family.
I love Roger Clemens.
You know,
fuck it.
Did some great things with the red sox before you went to Toronto.
Well,
we let them go.
Right then.
He fucking jumped on that poor police horse.
Jesus Christ.
You know,
that horse was wishing it was a fucking clydesdale when he got on his goddamn
back.
Um,
I'm just in a bad mood because I'm in San Francisco,
right?
I fucking came here yesterday and no guy has even looked at me.
No.
I came here yesterday and it was sunny out.
One of the rare sunny beautiful days and San Francisco when it is sunny out,
when the weather's nice can fuck with any city.
I'll even say in North America,
forget about the continental United States,
including Alaska and Hawaii and some of our tributaries like fucking Puerto
Rico.
Dare
I say Fox with any city.
Okay.
However,
on the usual cloudy,
rainy day,
this place,
there's a misery to this fucking place.
This it's cold,
wet air blowing against you as you walk up yet another fucking hill,
you know,
nothing is ever downhill.
It's always up a hill around a corner to an even steeper hill,
you know,
and they still have all that mamas and Papas,
although leaves are Brown,
Hippie vibe going out here a little bit,
even all the evil people from fucking a silicone valley,
which I still never know quite where that is.
It's somewhere down near like San Jose.
I just don't know where it begins and where it ends.
But silicone to me and my level of intellect,
the amount of books that I've read in life,
silicone to me is and will always be what's in fake titties.
So,
you know,
I don't know what they're doing.
I actually flew up here,
uh,
rented a helicopter and flew up here with a couple people,
had a great fucking time,
picked up a couple of hours and um,
we went by this giant building that was this huge circle and I was like,
what the fuck is that?
That looks like,
I dunno,
it looks like like the Pentagon.
If it was groovy man,
right.
I was like,
what is that?
And my buddy Jesse goes is probably,
maybe it's apple.
I never seen a building.
Like it was just a total circle.
Then in the middle there was like all of this,
like it looked like a jungle in the middle,
you know?
And if you look down you could see the employee screaming and waving going,
get me Outta here.
He's still alive.
Steve is still alive.
I think that's what it said.
But I was too busy focusing on not hitting somebody else while I was up there.
It turns out it was the apple building.
Very impressive,
very fucking impressive structure.
And then we went right by Stanford.
And so that stadium,
I buddy was hitting me with a trivia before we got there.
He goes,
I went to a game,
I went to a Superbowl.
He claimed it was the only super bowl ever played at a college or something like
that.
Which isn't true because they played a bunch at the rose bowl and also a two
lane maybe said the last one played at a college stadium.
Was it that,
I forget what it was.
Don't blame him.
Blame me for not remembering.
And uh,
I was able to get sad.
I said was the,
uh,
40 niners dolphins at Stanford Stadium?
Only because I had recently read that that's where they played that game.
And because I got that right,
he then had to be like,
what was the score?
I was like,
I dunno.
But Fulton Walker took a kickoff back for the first time.
A soup bowl history.
It's like 35,
10.
So anyways,
we fucking land at San Francisco International Airport,
which it's so,
it's so much different.
You know,
when you,
when you actually get to see how cool it fuck it looks when you sit in the back
of the tube,
you know,
and you're just looking out the back,
just praying,
you know,
just please get this thing on the fucking ground.
It's different when you come up there.
It's fucking amazing.
It's expensive as shit,
but it's amazing,
right?
So we land,
everything's going great.
And uh,
I ended up doing this thing with the,
what is it?
The San Francisco,
uh,
sketch fest.
And um,
I did this,
what was it?
The,
uh,
who's the guy from Cuba?
Castro,
the Castro theater with Kevin Pollak.
And we just went out and,
uh,
sort of an interview,
just riff and fucking around and then people came up and ask questions
afterwards.
I want to thank everybody who showed up.
It was like one in the afternoon.
All of these people showed up.
It was a great time and a canvas,
just the greatest fucking dude ever.
And we actually,
I got to do a scene with him in a movie coming up called a front runner.
It's coming up this year.
Um,
we had a great time doing that.
And uh,
you know,
San Francisco,
why in a bad mood belt?
The south sounds great.
It's all great.
It's all fucking great.
Then I get to my hotel,
of course,
I show up right in the lady takes my driver's license.
I forgot.
Did Not just show it to her like she took the driver's license,
right?
So then she starts clicking on a keyboard and say,
Hey,
can you do me a favor?
Keep,
can you not type any personal information on a license?
And she got all this fucking attitude.
She goes,
I am not,
I will tell you what I'm typing in.
And Pablo and his whole fucking,
you know,
snap to the 12th to the six,
whatever the fucking kids say,
I want to be like lady lady,
you're not going to tell me what you're going to do.
I'm going to tell you what you're not going to do,
you fucking cunt.
But of course they can't say that,
you know,
I can't say that do,
I don't know what the fuck happened to customer service,
but her fucking added to the way she talked to me,
it was like I told her how to parent your kid.
So then she looks at me up.
Of course they don't fucking half me down cause I probably miscommunicated when
I was going to come up here anyways.
I just didn't say a fucking word.
Right.
And then she went out of her way and actually got me,
you know,
she didn't get it.
I mean out of the way she fucking did her job.
Fuck her.
I still fuck her
sir.
I'm going to tell you when,
but like what enough.
I felt like I was getting booked.
I just,
I,
I fucking,
I don't understand what has happened to customer service.
So then I was just like,
oh,
all right,
fucking whatever.
All right.
And then this hotel turns out they don't have the two things that I need in a
hotel.
The only two fucking things I need other than a fucking door that doesn't open
up out into the parking lot.
In other words,
I'm not staying in a motel.
Okay.
And all I need is some sort of gym and an ironing board.
That's it.
This hotel has,
neither
has,
neither has little steam fucking machine.
I don't want to steam my fucking clothes.
I practice my drum shit,
but I'm on the road and bring a little practice pad.
And after all these years of trying to find a fucking table that fits right in
the ironing board was there the whole time he just play standing up.
Okay.
And you can adjust it down.
If it's not high enough,
you just put a couple of towels underneath and then it's at the height you
needed to be.
They don't fucking have one.
Um,
and then lastly,
I went to go get a burrito and I fucked up.
Like San Francisco makes the best burritos.
Right?
They got the best break perfected them.
I don't know where they came from.
I believe France invented the Burrito.
I'm not sure.
Um,
so there's this fucking,
I'm not gonna name the Burrito place,
but evidently they got a great spot in the mission and I'm all the way down near
the fucking touristy area where they got like rides to Alcatraz.
I'm like,
I'm not fucking going all the way out there.
I want to watch both these fucking football games.
And no one behold,
I find that there's,
there's a guy that,
there's a one that's in on everybody's top 10 lists that makes a fucking Burrito
in the mission,
but also has another location down near the fishermen place.
Right.
The wharf down here.
So I'm like,
all right,
well I know it's probably not gonna be as good as the original cause that's the
original oven and blah,
blah,
blah.
So I fucking go to the new,
this obviously the second one that they opened,
I show up.
Right.
And uh,
yeah,
it's like fucking,
I don't know,
a group of Ford Front of me in a group of two in front of me.
And you would've thought the amount of time it took them to order a fucking
Burrito,
you would've thought that they were trying to like,
you know,
it was like war time and they were trying to catch the last flight out before
the,
you know,
the impending regime or whatever.
It's going to send them to a fucking labor camp.
That's like how long they want negotiating this.
And what kills me is these four people that took for fucking ever then the two
people behind him who had enough time to fucking go on Youtube,
find out what's in a Burrito to a fucking supermarket,
buy the Shit and cook one.
That's the amount of time they had it.
They step up to the register.
It's their moment of truth to order a Burrito and they'll start looking at the
menu.
Uh,
we're good.
ugh.
Okay.
Fucking ridiculous.
So I get up there.
What do you want?
Give me an original burrito.
Chicken.
Yeah.
Chips and salsa and a water to go.
Cash.
Thank you.
Step aside over.
Yeah.
How hard is that?
Okay.
You know what it is,
is somewhere in the last century became illegal to punch somebody in the back of
the head when they were taking too long in a line.
And now everybody,
they just,
you know,
they just a little too comfortable.
Yeah.
They're just a little too comfortable.
So I'm standing there and,
uh,
you know,
now in behind the fucking couple that you know,
over the salsa line,
Salsa line,
salsa,
salsa line and uh,
I'm behind them again and it's taking them forever to get fucking salsa.
Yeah.
The fucking looking around and they're looking at other people.
It's like,
use your fucking braid.
Mild,
medium,
hot
the fuck
touchdown sites.
Or when then say,
[inaudible] go marching in
[inaudible]
oh,
plenty of time left.
No,
there isn't.
What am I talking about?
I thought that was fucking one 18 into the third quarter.
Well,
I guess there's plenty of time left,
Roy.
This is the way the game is played nowadays.
It's like,
do they go for two here?
There's only a quarter in a minute.
13 left.
Kick the fucking extra point.
Um,
yeah.
Jesus Christ.
That guy just had a soul patch on the back of his head.
Wow.
You know,
tough.
You have to be to have that calf because somebody just,
how hard it would be to not tell the guy how fucking annoying that.
It's like,
dude,
I just want to fucking,
can you just grow it out?
A shave it off.
MMM.
All right.
Touchdown saints.
Yeah.
Touched my prediction lives.
This is such a disturbing commercial with this guy falls off the cruise ship.
This is one of my biggest fucking fears in life.
You know what I mean?
Just being in the fucking ocean,
praying for hypothermia to set it before some of something comes up to you and
just takes a bite out of you.
Can you imagine when you see that fucking shark fin?
Just break the water,
you know,
and you know,
you smell the thing.
Fucking wild animals.
You could smell them from a mile away to the point.
I don't understand how they're able to kill anybody.
Yeah,
yeah.
No you didn't.
You haven't go to the fucking sue when you just smell those goddamn lions.
I guess that'd be everything stinks out there,
you know?
Um,
anyways.
Okay.
And they just leave the guy in the fucking ocean
fucking really bothers me.
I this gotta be somebody complaining about that,
you know,
once a year that seems to happen or every couple of years,
like somebody goes on a honeymoon and their spouse fucking falls overboard.
You know,
I gotta look that up.
How many fucking times?
What do you,
what are the odds?
Are the odds higher on a honeymoon or FD been married for awhile?
Like how many times somebody who's like fucking thrown his spouse overboard,
you know?
And if it's anywhere near the number that I think it is,
I want to know why it doesn't have its own Hashtag.
I think we need to start a Hashtag on Twitter.
Let me just do fucking three seconds of a
research here.
Spouse,
how do you spell spouse?
I just spelled spas.
Spouse.
What would I look up?
Your spouse,
dead
cruise ship.
Uh,
significant other question mark.
When a passenger dies it see what you need to know.
Oh my God,
what do they do?
Do they have a burial?
At Sea,
you know,
with the Carnival cruise line flag and they try to make it look official is just
sitting there looking at fucking Gilligan and Gofer.
Um,
so that the guy's named Golfer guy became like a senator.
Husband pleads not guilty and wife's cruise ship killing.
Oh my God.
Cheese.
If they,
if they figure out,
ah,
can you imagine that?
Wow.
That's,
that's just cruel and unusual punishment.
The bad enough you killed somebody.
The fact that you would send them to that of a lonely,
brutal death.
I Utah Man who allegedly brutally murdered his wife last month while onboard and
Alaska.
Oh,
we just,
it killed her on,
yeah.
All right,
well Jesus,
there's some fucking serious music dude who composed that,
hey,
this guy killed his wife.
This guy killed his wife on a fucking cruise ship in this Guy Jay.
We need,
we need music for that.
And that guy,
you just come,
I can't get back to the fade in that one.
That was what the Jimmy page army a fucking guitars there.
Can you imagine that?
You want us to write the next stairway to heaven and now you just write in
fucking music.
You know,
that fits people dying on a fucking cruise ship.
Okay.
This dude is accused of first degree murder in the death of his 39 year old
wife.
Uh,
she must've fucking choked her and shuffle board or something.
I'm sorry.
A Kenneth's wife was found dead in her cruise ship cabin on July 25th.
That's the couple had a domestic dispute.
Oh my God.
D there's,
you know,
they should throw this guy overboard.
Jesus Christ
said blood was spread throughout the room on multiple surfaces.
Who's immediately detained by ship security in a witness said that the,
the defendant allegedly told him she would not stop laughing at me.
Jesus Christ.
What the food she ridiculing him.
Okay.
You know,
it's funny if this was the other way around.
Yeah,
I think the woman goes free if,
if she just said he was fat shaming her,
like she put on some baby weight or something like that and he just,
he wouldn't stop laughing at me and I just made me feel like I was small
each year over 4,000 men laugh at their recently not pregnant wise,
causing them to feel bad about themselves.
Um,
okay.
He had been acting terrible all night.
The source claim adding at some point that evening ac.
Yeah.
She sent me not stop laughing at you and go for a walk.
What F wow.
What was going that he,
that guy is not just a straight up fucking psycho,
you know
like what the fuck was going on.
I mean movies could you make out of that relationship
like if,
if that guy never did anything wrong in his life and she was just so fucking
sadistic,
sadistic and his so gotten into his fucking head.
Yeah.
That her just laughing at him,
Pete,
that he fucking snap like that.
You know,
I'm just playing the other side.
I'm just playing devil's advocate here.
Interception Sal.
Window saints go marching in
[inaudible]
how annoying them.
I do the fucking person next to me.
Case Keatum
case case and drew.
Yeah,
those are the quarterbacks
used to be.
Joe Verse Phillip
Roger Verse Terry.
What are some of the great rivalry names?
Dan Verse Kenny.
Okay.
Dan Fouts first.
Kenny Anderson in that fucking freezing bowl.
Oh wait.
Definitely stepped out of bounds.
You can see there.
That's exactly
what happened there.
You can't see any grade between the white light gaze.
Kanombe got out of giant IPAD.
It's going to play a little donkey.
Kong put on a hat.
There you go.
Hugs all around like the game has been one on the safe side.
Okay.
Does it mean to the saints?
The uniforms look a little cheap.
I don't know what's going on.
They take some stripe away and this shirt,
it looks like they,
they should be playing on a half a field inside of hockey arena.
Um,
I write drill brazy,
he's got the ball.
Hey,
hands that off and that guy immediately it's tackled what a waste of a play.
Um,
when o two to go in the fucking third quarter.
You want me announced the rest of the third quarter for you?
Some of you guys like when I do this shit.
All right,
number 29,
he's upset.
What is he upset about?
I Dunno,
but a guy with fucking night vision glasses is talking to them.
Listen,
I just got from the gun range.
I didn't see what happened,
but I believe in you
29.
What the fuck is he doing out there?
That's a running back number,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Maybe he's mad at,
maybe he's mad at case.
Yeah,
get off my case.
Keenum sorry.
Jubilees drops back to pass over the fucking middle.
When those sates scared of fucking first down.
Woo.
Why do I give a shit about this game?
It's literally just cause I told Paul Versey that I thought the sates are going
to win,
that I need this to happen to fill me up in life because I'm a married guy and
you know,
and the compliments,
they're,
they're on their own other we're on,
I'm on like a compliment rationed.
I get one a season and there's only one season in La.
I used to get four a year when I lived in New York.
Now I'm out in La.
I get about one.
Um,
how do you get that job?
Is Water Water Guy?
Like how do you know who's fucking thirsty?
Nobody ever points them out.
You just kind of walk up.
You stick it,
you know?
All right.
I swear to God,
the black guy in this commercial looks like they stuck his head on like an eight
year old's body.
Um,
although I do like this commercial
built,
nobody gives a fuck.
Most people aren't even watching this.
They don't even know what you're talking about.
You're literally doing common commentary for fucking Youtube video that doesn't
exist while they're listening to your podcasts.
Get back on the fucking game here.
I'm fucking Steelers.
What are the,
what is what?
The Steelers,
how many times are they going to look past the opponent that week?
That's,
that's,
that's what they say it out there.
They're saying that they focus too much on the New England patriots because you
know who's kidding who?
They beat the Patriots earlier this year,
you know?
Yeah.
That was a touch.
I don't know.
You know what I don't understand about,
you know,
whether it's a catch or whether it's not a catch,
is the fact the ground can't cause a fumble if you're running.
But if you're,
it can cause it can cause an incomplete pass.
That how it works.
I Dunno.
I have no idea.
But I liked that commercial.
I just saw that guy was like practicing speed skating,
like in his living room.
That'll be like the latest thing people will get.
Rather than reading about nutrition,
they'll literally spend like fucking 10 grand on that thing.
Yeah.
And then they'll have some sort of app where they can project it onto their TV
where they can,
you can be,
you know,
in different speed skating or arenas around the fucking world.
I saw this picture today on the Internet.
It just,
fuck it.
It made me feel so goddamn old.
It was this woman.
Right?
Where's that place where people go to vacation,
right?
It's like the,
the ocean looks absolutely perfect.
And then Z,
these grass,
like these huts and the hover out over the water,
you know,
one tsunami in everybody's dead right?
But it looks like absolute paradise.
Okay.
And the picture of this woman,
she's in a thong,
right leaning on one leg,
so her butt cheeks sticking out and she's looking at the huts and over her head,
she,
she's making,
you know,
those,
that stupid thing where you make the heart with your hands.
She still wasn't that,
you know,
and that it made me feel so fucking old.
It's like,
what if it happened to just go into a fucking unbelievable place and just
geeking out and taken a picture of yourself and you have that look on your face
like you can't believe you there.
Like she literally used that paradise to enhance her whole fucking like,
I don't know what the word is her,
her Nis,
I dunno,
the Selfie just,
it just makes everybody act like a Douche who doesn't know how to behave when
they get their road show.
In other words,
they behave like myself.
What's going on?
I stepped out of bounds,
eight yards.
He picked up eight yards.
I'll tell you right now,
you know what I tell you?
Who's going to make a big a lot of fucking money?
Whoever owns the cleanest store in the mall of America.
It's my prediction that every one of these men is soda fans are going to fucking
at the end of this game or they're all going to go out of the mall of America
and they're going to go into the Kleenex store.
They're going to get their own fucking,
you know,
Kleenex with their own initial on it.
Cause everybody's fucking special now.
And you can take a selfie.
But how sad you are actually no,
it would be amazing is if the vikings go to the Superbowl.
Okay.
And they play a home game.
Ah,
first.
oh.
When the saints go marching in there down to the fucking two yard line.
You guys like Pete Fountain?
Huh?
Put on the old gray bonnet.
I Love Pete Fountain.
Fuck.
You always had to kill a drummer,
right?
Played the shit out of the clarinet,
you know what I mean?
And he's never had any sexual harassment scandals.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Oh,
Jesus Christ,
this fucking guy.
This guy hurt.
Now what happened?
What happened to the guy?
Does he got to go inside the tent?
Well,
thank God there's an 80 year old bald white guy to help him off the field.
The dude was so short,
he couldn't even lean on him.
He's probably gonna have a separated shoulder.
By the time he gets over to that little fucking little pop tent they put him in.
Um,
hey,
I think I found the MP three player that now that I'm seeing this poor bastard
with the umbilical cord hanging out,
I'm getting out of the apple world ready as I said that,
that Weirdo just stared at me in the galaxy commercial.
Like he knew I was going to fuck it,
do it.
Um,
I'm going to get a new,
uh,
MP.
I'm going to go with one of those Sony,
you know,
and I want to tell you guys the exact model so you can be like,
dude,
oh my God.
Really?
You're going to buy the
yeah,
I am.
Because I have a bunch of music that I didn't get on fucking a apple and those
round building cunts.
Okay.
But the forest in the middle where they reeducate their employees that want to
ask for more money or maybe pay the poor bastards that put together their
products so they don't jump to their fucking deaths.
Uh,
how crazy would be if they still advertise on this podcast after that?
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
I want to fucking get out of that world.
I want to go,
I'm like,
I still want to use this shit,
but I still don't.
I don't like how they were all there.
Like fucking a,
this is our shit over here.
I should only works with our,
with our shit.
None of that shit works with other people's Shit.
Do you want to use that shit?
You got to buy our other shit to use our shit.
Fuck people's other shit.
We're going to fucking own everything.
Oh,
so wait,
what is your problem?
How many billions of dollars d I,
I swear to God at that point.
Um,
I know a promoted like that.
I know promoted like that.
He wants to make all the money.
You know,
it's not enough that he's making the most money.
He wants to make all the money and it actually gives them joy
when,
when other people,
uh,
when other people's,
you know,
other promoters in his town are not doing well.
He'll just say,
oh,
did you hear about someone sold?
They poke solids.
I a guy took a bath
and I'd be like,
Oh,
I bet that makes you happy.
I fucking it.
Um,
anyways,
I guess I never gave you guys a Hashtag,
uh,
for the cruise ships.
Why don't you come up with one?
Oh,
here comes to 10 pop up tent.
Dick's sporting good.
All right,
let's see.
A Dick.
What happened?
Did he hit your left ball?
You're right ball.
All right,
we're going to freeze it here.
We're going to do a little fucking put a little desk and next on it and a,
I think you'd be all right.
All right.
Drew Brees hands the ball off a knee guy runs it to everybody.
Evidently there was supposed to be a hole there.
You know,
when I was a kid,
I thought that running backs rather than running around the outside,
the reason why they ran in the middle's cause they thought they'd get famous for
trying to do something so impossible.
Um,
what do you guys think is going to happen here?
Actually,
you already know.
I say that they're going to score on third goal,
right?
Unless they try and run it three fucking times.
How about a little play action fake here.
Drove for the love of fucking Christ.
Oh,
by the way,
congratulations to Liverpool.
Huh?
Liverpool.
Be fucking man city.
Guess you guys didn't realize I've been paying attention a little bit to the
premier league.
That soccer for everybody here in North
America.
Drew Brees throws that Dan went them saints go marching.
Hm.
It's fucking 17 too,
mother fucking 13.
All right.
Okay.
Case Kayden case.
Caden,
he's on the case Canaan.
They must do a bunch of shit like that,
right?
Anytime.
Uh,
you know,
they always have the ponds,
right?
You must do a bunch of those things.
Jesus Christ.
This is that's becoming a tale of two halves.
It comes drew Brees.
He's going to break their hearts.
I'll tell you right now then there,
right now,
the last ride on the rollercoaster at the mall of America is happening.
This is an overall sadness that is going to descend on that mall right now.
There's a bunch of people that do not give a fuck.
Okay?
Two white guys trying to do a cool handshake.
The A,
I don't know what they just did their,
some sort of jerk off fucking motion by drew Brees is he gave the okay sign,
you know,
well,
these are the times.
Is it okay that I'm stroking your Dick?
I think that that's what that meant.
I think that was very progressive by drew Brees.
Um,
all right.
If you could tell I'm doing this thing early and I have yet to get any of the
advertising.
I don't have any fucking,
uh,
any of the questions or anything.
So at some point I'm going to have to fucking hit pause or I could text my
fucking guy here to send me the bullshit.
Right?
That could happen.
Let me hit pause.
You don't listen this fucking crap.
Oh,
do ya
Johnny or do you the fuck is going on with the Black Hawks this year.
Let me,
let me,
I got to hit pause and not put you through this shit.
All right,
I'm back.
Oh,
you know what I,
I was going to say is if Minnesota wins this game and then goes to the Superbowl
and uh,
I'm actually a vikings fan from way back in the day,
to be honest with you.
I don't know why I'm,
I'm just being a Douche right now.
Like said,
I just predicted this upset and I don't care if the Viking sweat,
ah,
right up the middle for first dad 1302 to go in the game.
He's not,
and he's not in like,
they didn't just give up 14 points in a row.
Every fucking guy now acts like they just reinvented football.
Look at this,
all those people block forum.
And then when there was finally a fucking guy who could tackle him,
then he did.
And this guy gets up like he's Steve Devacy,
Jim Brown,
get up fucking nod.
Oh,
the old man.
Oh No,
this is,
this is what you sound like.
The closer you get to death,
you know,
you're like,
well,
why isn't it one way or used to be case Keenan?
He is on a strict no passing diet right now.
They saw that last one.
They're like,
fuck this guy just handed off.
Now why aren't you nodded?
How come you're not nodding?
No
one got stuff right at the God damn line.
Everybody.
Anybody makes a good play.
They appointed the name of the back of the Jersey.
Anytime they fucking don't make a play,
they're looking for a flag or they run off the field.
Anyways,
if I can get through this God damn point,
if Minnesota actually goes to the God damn Superbowl,
it's a fucking home game.
All right.
Everything there is purple.
There's no way you got to have like a prince themed halftime show.
Do you think he would have played it?
Think he would've come to the yet.
What?
It had to have prince come back.
Look at that fucking throw case.
Keenum shaking off the interception of the saint.
Say it's not a catch.
They say it's not a catch.
Right.
Says,
oh my God,
I can't even deal how fucking great and it's driving me crazy.
Case Keaton,
everybody stopped shouting,
settle down.
This is a great fucking throw.
Oh,
he just drops it right in there.
I don't know.
A little bit of wobbly there.
In the end he caught it,
but did he catch it long enough?
Case Keenum gets to the aisle.
They got it or not in time.
Not In time.
The challenge flag
these degenerate gambling.
Looking at head coach.
It's fucking white.
Probably cries yourself to sleep.
That's such a terrible thing to say.
Why would I say that?
All right.
He's on the ground.
He has it.
He still has it.
If they call this not a fucking catch.
We'll give a shit.
All right.
There you go.
That's a catch.
He's got it.
It's got it.
Yeah.
What are they going to look at?
Okay,
Jesus fucking Christ.
How long do you have to have it?
Oh my God.
Now I've got to see this replay.
58 fucking time.
He,
as you see right there,
Deli has it against his navel.
It is,
is his fucking happy trail.
Um,
let's get pleading his case.
Take back your Red Hanky.
MMM.
All right.
I know you guys do you guys,
I don't think you want to fucking lit this.
I've really limited my God.
Damn.
Here.
Let's talk about fucking a,
let's limit it even more and I'll talk to my six British fans over there.
Um,
man city.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
It was like a full fucking bottle of water and it's every on too.
And I fucking hate that shit.
That'd be,
yeah.
There's minerals in it.
Yeah.
I can taste it.
It tastes fucking weird.
Did the water rushed through a plastic rock?
What does it taste so fucking awful.
I hate I fucking hate yard.
MMM.
Anyways.
Yeah.
This supposed to be like the best bottled water.
It tastes like shit.
I,
and how do I know it's from the French Alps.
I'll drink anything.
Poland spring to Sani.
Okay.
Smart water.
I'll drink that box water.
I don't give a shit even though it tastes like you're drinking out of a shoe.
Fucking wet cardboard.
I know it's better for the environment,
but Jesus Christ.
Oh yeah,
you,
it was the worst was when you were a little kid.
You drank out of the garden hose and you didn't realize it was sitting in the
sun.
You'd had that fucking hot blast of Stale fucking water.
They'd probably been there for a week.
Jesus Christ.
So you know that taken out your fucking small intestine.
Um,
all right,
let's look up this man city shit.
All right,
man.
City Man City lost four to three to Liverpool.
Now.
Now for those of you who live in United States of Merker of Morocco,
mmm
man city evidently was fucking undefeated the whole year.
I guess that's really difficult.
It's difficult to do in any sports,
but I wasn't sure was soccer just seems like your score,
one goal and the game's over.
But I will tell you lately they've four to three to seven goals.
You've got to love that.
Yeah.
Got a fucking love that they lost the Liverpool home of the fucking Beatles.
That's all I know.
That's all I know about touch shit.
Oh,
let's talk about,
let's talk about dot eight Donny fucking case.
Kate,
I'm sacked.
Oh No.
He got the ball up.
Donald fucking Trump.
I got to say something,
man,
that was a low,
that is a low point in modern United States history.
And that's fucking saying something.
You just can't,
uh,
you know,
you just can't find it.
It's a fair balance.
So not even apologize and say,
Hey,
you know,
I shouldn't have said it that way,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
That was just a fucking like,
I dunno what,
and people still stick it by the guy.
Yeah.
What he street can unlock it is.
All right.
Here's his number two guy number four is going to hold the ball.
The little skinny guy.
He kicks the ball right down fucking metal.
It was one at one horn flies.
What is the,
uh,
Minnesota Vikings.
What is the Saints Guy Bitching about now?
What is he complaining about?
I'll tell you right now.
Okay.
If I fuck that fucking APP.
No.
She would've said no catch.
Yes you would've.
Yes you want.
If you just like my wife,
you just like my fucking white
Jesus.
You don't,
you're fat.
When you can see a man tits,
suddenly the Windbreaker,
oh,
he was saying the guy was down.
All right.
Nobody cares.
Bill.
This is one of the worst podcasts I've ever done.
I apologize.
Okay.
And I'm sure you guys will let me know.
All right.
Oh,
so the burrito ended up getting like at the,
it just sucked.
Wasn't wrapped tight or I guess I'm supposed to keep it in the foil.
I have no fucking idea.
And then the chicken was like overcooked.
You don't,
this is what happens.
This is what happens when you go to a city and you go,
you know what?
These people are known for this.
And then you as a tourist don't know where to go.
And you just go out and get one and then you go back to your city with the,
the,
the wrong information saying,
I went there,
their burrito sucked.
It didn't tell you I could make a better breed of than that.
You know,
that's like,
you know,
people go to Chicago,
New York and they say that their pizza sucks.
It's like,
well,
who did you hang out with?
Will you with people from the city?
Did they tell you where to fuck to go?
Um,
Oh,
you know what?
I want it to look up because people are sitting there saying,
oh,
they got it when peach fucking Donald Trump.
And it's just like,
well,
they impeach Bill Clinton.
He got impeached.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Hey,
he's going to have to leave.
And then he,
he didn't,
he just,
why didn't Bill Clinton leave?
And then I'll just write in peach,
right?
That she get me.
Are you spelling?
Peached there you go.
Impeached.
If Bill Clinton won,
why did he finish?
Gave Bill Clinton was impeached.
Why did he finish up?
I don't understand how he could have been impeached,
but he did not leave office.
All right.
Being at peach doesn't guarantee the person in peach has to leave office.
Here's some historical examples.
Uh,
the problem with your question is he was not impeached in a way to have to leave
office.
I see.
You really don't understand the difference between impeachment and having to
leave office now.
You didn't have to be that fucking conti about it.
Not True.
He wasn't peached for a public official impeach.
While this is just people arguing,
Bill Clinton was acquitted,
the Senate did not reach the two thirds majority needed to fully process is
impeachment.
To further break it down,
Clinton was impeached by the House on two charges.
The first being perjury.
The second being obstruction of justice following this,
he was acquitted by the Senate.
Yeah.
The impeachment process takes place in two steps.
First,
the president has to stick a cigar and somebody pussy.
No,
sorry.
First the president has to be impeached in the of Representatives.
That is the equivalent of an indictment.
Ah.
Then the president is tried in the Senate.
What?
The chief justice of the United States presiding.
Oh,
this is why all the lefties is saying,
we got to fucking kill these elections in October so we can get Trump out.
I was like,
what the fuck are they talking about?
So then they could actually and indict him in the house and then impeach him in
the Senate.
Yeah.
It requires a two thirds vote of the Senate to removing impeachment.
You think if he got impeached,
right?
If it went to the Senate and he got impeached,
like I actually think that he would leave before they took the vote.
He would get on his own fucking plane and he would just leave and he'd be on the
f like just so his ego could handle it.
Like,
you know,
you're not going to come walking in here and have me pack up my shit and have me
escorted out.
Like I just get fought fired at,
you know,
some fucking corporation.
All right.
Yeah.
I haven't been,
I don't take the amount of time that I take to comb my hair over the top of my
fucking had to be treated this way.
All right.
So evidently they fucking didn't think the guy was down.
I'm literally commentating a game that you already know the results of that
you're not watching.
This is the stupidest fucking thing I've ever done.
All right.
I'll be honest with you.
I'm just,
I'm fucking lonely.
Okay.
I just felt like talking to somebody can,
can you guys just be there for me?
All right.
The fucking fucking guy did his God damn job.
You hit it twice.
Hey,
how about a round of applause for the person who's making the field goal
kickers,
helmets.
Now they finally,
you know,
they gave him like two bars.
You know,
I have back in the day,
they just had that like Fred Cox,
Joe size man.
All those guys just had that one bar across the front of their fucking,
I mean,
I dunno.
I Dunno how those people survived.
All right.
You know,
and this is going to be a mercy pause right here.
I'm going to just wait for the,
all the information to come from my fucking podcast so I can actually do this.
Okay?
Yes.
We'll send over in five getting advertising now.
All right.
I still got advertising.
Um,
all right,
I'll talk to you in two seconds here.
Okay.
All right.
I'm back and I got all the materials I need here.
By the way,
all went to sate stay fucking scored again.
They were up by one point.
That's where I am in the game.
They just,
Vikings just got a pass interference call with number 19 or some shit on the
vikings who has the smallest shoulder pads I've ever seen in my life.
Remember the eighties how big fucking shoulder pads were?
What do they make those things out now?
I guess if everybody has small ones,
then it's a fucking,
it's a fair game.
Oh,
by the way.
So
basically what happened with Bill Clinton was he got indicted in the House of
Representatives and then when it went to the Senate,
they needed two thirds of the vote and none of the Democrats voted to impeach
him.
So that's how we got off.
The liberals look the other way with the sexual harassment,
and you know,
it's all just politics.
It's not like one side's better than the other.
If it was a Republican,
they would have voted the,
oh,
they all would have voted the exact fucking opposite way except maybe one or two
fucking actually decent human beings.
Um,
and the result.
But,
so Bill Clinton got acquitted,
but he did lose his license to practice law because of that.
They're fucking unbelievable.
Unfuckable Lord of all.
One of the hardest things I think is to become a lawyer.
Just all like,
like trying to pass the bar and all of that.
You go through all of that shit and then what do you do?
You stick a cigar in some fucking woman's pussy.
That is it,
your wife and then you lie about it and then all that study and goes right out
the window.
Jesus Christ.
I love cigars and I love women,
but I'm telling you if I learned anything,
you got to keep them separate.
All right?
Okay,
let's do some advertising here.
Uh,
three reads.
All right honey,
that's the name of this new company.
There's an amazing free browser extension called honey.
Honey,
could you that millions and millions of people use everyday to save money.
Honey is the world.
The world's most popular money saving browser.
Add on.
It works on chrome,
Firefox,
safari,
all the major browsers.
And it's always free.
I have no idea what it is.
Oh,
it's his money saving browser.
Okay.
It only takes two clicks to add.
Oh honey.
So your browser,
uh,
when it starts working in the back,
it starts working in the background right away.
When you shop honey scans and tests,
millions of coupon codes all over the Internet to find you the biggest discount
on everything you buy online.
Well that's cool.
No more googling random coupon codes that don't end up working.
Yeah,
I was trying to buy all the fucking Minnesota hit a field goal.
Caden let them write down the Goddamn fills a minute,
29 left and they got drew Brees when the states.
Anyways,
I was trying to,
some fucking old lady can't even get up for it.
Um,
I tried to buy a Jersey for my nephew and I filled out where I lived,
all my credit card information,
all of this shit.
And then when I hit process to like,
Eh,
it's not in stock.
And then they kept all my information,
the pricks.
So,
uh,
why don't you try out honey?
But here's the best part of it.
Whenever you're ready,
the checkout haughty automatically applies the best coupon to your current.
There is no reason not to add honey to your browser.
It's free.
It will always save you cash on everything you were going to buy anyways.
Yeah,
this a no brainer.
If you're not using honey when you shop,
you're missing out on free money.
Saturday free money you're throwing away money is what you're doing
and honey
to your browser for free right now@atjoinhoney.com slash bird that's joined
honey.com/burr
the saints do not return minute 29 to go.
How the fuck did that kick off?
Take no time,
but guy caught it.
That must have been a split second,
right?
Simply safe.
Um,
hey bill,
stop using her pussy as a human dog.
Uh,
simply safe.
Studies show that security systems deter burglars.
It's a fact,
but there is still a burglar burglary every eight seconds in America.
Burglars don't give up.
Just because someone's house has a security system,
they find a house that isn't protected.
That's why securing your home with simply faith is truly is truly an necessity.
Simply safe is ridiculously smart and it senses and it's sensors will protect
every point of access to your home.
Plus,
if a burglar so much as tries to break in and ear shattering siren,
we'll let them know that the place that the police are already on their way.
Let's hope it's not your fucking old neighbor checking in on you.
They might have a heart attack.
Yeah,
drew Brees,
and complete best of all simply saves 24 seven monitoring is just 1,499 a month
to get ear splitting security.
They'll never lock you in a longterm contract with simply safe.
You'll even get a 60 day money back guarantee,
so there's no reason not to try it today.
Protect your home and family was simply safe by going to simply save bird.com
today.
That's simply saved bird.com to order today,
you're simply safe home security system.
Simply safe.
buffer.com s.
Let's say you spell simply,
simply safe bird.com why is it always earsplitting?
Why can't they have it?
Like just why don't they just have,
it sounded like somebody really tough.
You know,
like somebody breaks and you just have some guy,
you know,
really deep voice bitch get not good.
Right.
That wasn't a tough voice.
You know what I mean?
Somebody just says some crazy shit.
Yeah,
I'm going to fucking murder you,
right?
You said the creepiest voice ever.
You just whisper that.
Have that.
That's your alarm.
Okay,
I'm going to murder you.
Right?
Or maybe this is what it is.
Maybe it it fucking the alarm goes to your phone and then you see the person
breaking in and then you start talking all this shit like you're in there and
you're crazy.
You'll be all brave because you're not home.
Yeah,
I see you and your green shirt,
you motherfucker,
I will let you on fire.
You know some crazy shit instead of,
all right.
stamps.com everybody.
Here's a new year's resolution.
You can actually keep a ad stance.
Stop,
add stamps.com to your business and save a ton of time and money year.
Um,
I use stamps.com any nice fucking defensive play.
I use stamps.com anytime I'm sending out my posters and I'm going to whore
myself out after shows and deal with cougars groping me.
Uh,
which of course goes unchecked because they're women and they're not held
accountable for their actions.
Plus stamps.com has postage discounts you can't get at the post office.
Not to mention it's a fraction of the cost of those super expensive postage
meters.
stamps.com send you a digital scale that automatically calculates exact postage.
You will never overpay or underpaid for poachers postage.
Again,
I use stamps.com B club because I already told you why and I if I can figure it
out,
you can figure out cause I'm a moron.
And right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus drew Brees throwing fuck postage and a digital
scale ready for a happier new year.
Ready for happy new year.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone on top of the homepage and type in bur
bur that stamps.com enter burr.
All right,
number three,
Bobby.
A bear if they brought it back from the fucking retirement is loosening up is
what the needs to wear that number.
Yeah,
he's fucking loosening up his leg here to kick a fucking field goal,
which would win it.
Oh my God.
Was My prediction true?
Are these poor viking fans going to get fucked again?
Are they going to be crying at the mall of America?
How much?
How many yards does he need?
They need like another 15 yards.
Oh.
Oh,
okay.
Here we go.
The Vikings are one play away
and let's,
this guy comes in and just kits like a fucking 70 yarder.
Oh,
you gotta catch that?
You got to catch that.
Okay.
Hey,
fuck.
I want to throw it was right there.
Drew Brees.
Ah God.
The coach has on his reading glasses.
He's already in the f off season.
It's going to read catcher in the rye or some shit.
Come on,
man.
Come on drove.
Why do I give a shit?
I,
the Vikings have had a drought of the states.
One in 2010 I just want to be right.
I said the states are going to win.
I apologize to everybody in Minneapolis,
Saint Paul Duluth.
Oh No.
First down fucking fuck the sates.
Oh my God,
I have to turn this up.
Oh my God.
He's in the guys feel goal rage.
Oh No,
no.
You know it's funny.
I Love Minneapolis.
I don't want you people to be sad.
I was just joking around.
Oh,
case and puts the hat on,
takes it off,
puts it on,
holds his head.
How am I ever going to talk to my loved ones again?
Holy Shit.
Ten nine eight Jesus Christ through,
what are we doing?
I learned from Tony Romo was the play clock.
You fucking moron.
All right.
40 seconds to go was like Jesus.
He's nonchalant.
I learned from Tony Romo.
You want to,
you want to kick it with four seconds left.
Just,
I think it's four seconds left cause then you don't have to kick off like that's
how long it feel gold takes.
Yeah,
but with Tony Romo after it's done,
Bob Lynn and it probably takes 11 seconds.
I'll come on.
He shits on Deion Sanders.
I can give him a little fucking rough time.
I love Tony Romo,
by the way.
All right.
Practice tea.
You kicked it.
Okay.
I put it into the net.
37 seconds to go.
Oh my God.
Is this
the mall of America?
Oh God.
Why didn't I invest in the Kleenex store at the mall of America?
One of the dumbest things I ever did.
Blitz and drew Brees fucking picked it up.
It's a catch.
Oh,
I'm going to talk so much shit to Diversey.
I'm going to talk so much shit.
Diversey yeah.
What did I say?
I called it.
Oh,
he's the ball was bobbling.
Yeah,
he got it.
He got it.
Did he catch it enough times for it to be a kid and all that.
Dot.
Not not,
no.
That's not a catch.
The little tail was hanging down on the bottom.
See now here go.
Here goes all the fucking drama.
This is going to be 20 fucking minutes of this shit.
All right.
I'm not even looking at this guy damn game at this point.
That is not a catch of Vikings.
C'Mon.
You gotta throw the challenge flag.
Did the vikings coach just come from the gun range?
What is with those goddamn glasses?
Dah,
Dah.
Yeah.
You can see the point of the ball touches the ground are right there.
It's not a catch.
Everybody knows.
It's not a catch for the fucking love of Christ.
All right.
This is just hilarious.
The first letter that I got this week,
there's the water guy.
Now how did he know the guy wanted the water down his back when?
That'd be annoying.
Tba.
Fuck is the name of this one dear Billy Bo's.
Huh?
I had been a big fan of the podcast and you stand up for several years now.
I am writing you to tell you that I owe you a lot.
Oh Jesus,
look good.
This was about a year ago.
I heard you first say that every now and then you would look into the mirror and
call yourself a tub of fuck
I do.
I thought it was hilarious and it made me realize I was a tub of fuck as well.
Look at that.
We're bonded.
Um,
okay.
Fucking sound.
ICLOUD preferences.
I don't know my password and you won't give it.
You won't get me a second chance so I don't want to update it.
All right.
Since last February,
I have woken up every morning and told myself that I am a tub of fuck.
I made my phone wallpaper,
a picture of me when I was at my heaviest two 55 so whenever I unlock my phone
there was a reminder of the tub of fuck I am and no longer wanted to beat.
That's great.
I'm proud to announce that I have lost 70 pounds in
11 months.
Dude,
that's awesome.
And honestly I owe you a big thanks for giving me the motivation to do this
because of you and Joe Rogan.
Probably more Joe Rogan.
He's actually had shape.
I have done a lot of things in the last year that have taken me out of my
comfort zone.
You've been a great inspiration in my life in many different ways.
Hope you and the lovely meal and the baby have a great 2018 from one tub of fuck
to another.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Well,
that was just,
you know,
for all you guys know that I wrote that there was really no question there after
failure of you.
Did he say that was a catch?
What?
How the fuck was that a catch?
You saw the little cone to the ball.
Ks.
Kingdom cannot grow a beard,
goddammit.
He's trying.
What the fuck?
Oh my God.
Everybody's got on their granny glasses.
All right,
drew Brees.
What's he gonna do?
He's gonna get a hands off the fucking ball and nothing happens,
but he didn't fumble it.
Yeah.
All right.
You guys want to listen to this shit?
Do you want to listen to the sound of a bunch of 80,000 people have already
started crying to go to the mall of America?
If I ran the mall of America,
I would say free rollercoaster rides for the entire month.
Yeah.
Well maybe for the week.
You know,
they've gotta make that money over there.
I can't imagine how much,
Oh my God.
How does this always happen to the fucking vikings?
It always happens to them when they're at home.
Everything with like 15 in one.
Yeah.
The dirty birds came in and it just,
okay.
Somehow came in and fucking beat him.
It's unreal.
Done.
Then they have a game against like the fucking Redskins or something like that
and 88 well they had the game won and then it just fucking went away.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
All right,
here we go.
Bobby a bears.
Yeah.
Fucking lining up for the kick.
The kick is up plow and it's good.
Oh No.
Yes.
Oh.
When the saints go marching in,
Oh my God,
the game is not over cause they got case Keenum
what the fuck?
I'm already typing in capital letters to Paul Versey.
What the fuck did I say?
What did I say?
All right.
Let me turn this down.
What did I do to the fucking thing?
Is there an exit button?
Exit?
Holy fucking shit.
I can't,
I can't fucking believe they came back and won this game.
I do.
I just say,
you know,
I don't know shit about football.
I just had a feeling sad to feeling.
I was like drew Brees.
He's like third all time passing.
He never gets the respect he fucking deserves.
I think he's got,
I said it last week on the podcast.
I'm texting Paul Versey right fucking now Paul for Z.
Should I do,
I should wait.
Right?
What does this guy takes it back?
Yeah.
All right.
25 seconds left case.
Keenum
it's going to present his case that he is,
he is the key.
Numb to them winning.
Sorry.
What the fuck?
I mean,
they did a bunch for Aaron.
Judge.
I can't have fun with case kingdoms name.
That's what I'm going to do someday.
You know,
when I retire from being a comedian,
I'm going to go straight headlines for sports pages,
you know,
and I'll finally get to do all my pun jokes that I'm not allowed to do in a
comedy.
You do a Pun joke in a comedy club,
you're going to get a grown and people get you do enough of,
and people going to ask for their fucking money back.
All right.
The Daily News,
the New York Post,
all of these guys,
they live on it.
Uh,
I'll,
I'll fall.
Start false start.
Everybody's pointing at everybody else.
A little disco dancing on the Vikings.
Oh,
Jason,
look at that guy.
How much does his breath stink at fucking beard?
He's probably still get cereal in there.
Oh,
that wasn't good.
That's not the way you went.
That's not the way you want to start your two minute offense.
I like the Vikings when I was a kid,
cause purple was my favorite color when I was a little kid.
I wanted to,
I wanted to be a painter now,
like of art.
I would just wanted to paint houses.
I thought it was going to,
that would be a cool job.
And uh,
all right.
Prevent defense there on the 38 yard line.
Don't take it.
Dump Penalty.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
I just wanted to paint houses and I was going to paint everybody's house purple
whether they liked it or not.
Cause that was my favorite color.
So right out of the gate,
you know I was a con.
Um,
oh Jesus.
Here we go.
Paul Versey a we go,
I'm actually gonna I'm going to text it right now cause if I'm wrong you guys
will,
I will put the sound on,
you'll get to listen to me deleted.
Okay.
Dude,
I fucking called it called.
It's why is it so much fun being right about sports?
It's probably cause you s you know,
I'm so wrong in the rest of my life.
Just feels good.
Every once in a while incomplete.
It only took fucking two seconds off.
All right.
You know,
this is going to be boring.
The amount of time this is going to fucking let me read the next God damn
question.
Is it going to be another love letter?
Oh,
bill tip on making oatmeal.
Okay.
I started eating steel cut oats and uh,
they,
they have this gooey consistency unless you just keep stirring the fucking
thing.
He said get an instant pot and you could make steel cut oats in like three to
four minutes.
They're like $90 on Amazon.
Yeah.
Oh,
I should use honey.
See if I can get it for 87 if you go to your website and click the link,
they'll even throw you a little bit of cash.
They are chief.
Uh,
the fuck is an instapot.
Yeah.
Do you mean like a microwave?
Insta pot.
Let me see this.
It's like a vaporizer for oatmeal.
Insta pot.
I need to Google a fucking picture of that.
Instapot that looks like I've complete piece of shit.
Okay.
Oh,
in Stan Pot.
What does that,
what you wrote?
My losing my mind.
Where was it?
Oh,
you wrote Insta Pot.
It's instant.
Instant pot.
Like I'll have this breakfast made in an instant.
Oh,
but in,
on Amazon it says in step pot.
Maybe the instant pot is fucking ripping them off.
All right.
What is it?
It's balling young.
39 what down is it?
Yeah.
Case Kane and back for a fucking pass.
Throws the ball incomplete.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
Instapot is
hundred and 20 bucks.
So I'm like,
this is just going to be something else in my fucking cupboard because I can't
wait an extra 26 minutes of my oats.
You like how this person was just trying to help me out?
I'm still being a jerk about it.
I am into,
um,
I didn't see that New Matt Damon movie about downsizing,
but I am all about that shit.
I just fucking,
I had a lot of layoffs in my wardrobe.
I just sent everything.
Fuck it.
I'm going,
I'm going to be like,
I'm going to like three pairs of pants,
one black,
one blue,
and then just one for every shit moment of my fucking day.
Uh,
so,
oh my God.
No,
no.
Fucking it.
That could not have just happened.
Oh my God.
I have to,
I can't fucking please the greatest podcast ever that could not have just
happened.
How do you let that happen?
Holy Shit.
All right.
Wait on fucking believable.
Oh,
you know what?
I didn't say the thing.
When I've texted to [inaudible],
I almost said,
dude,
I fucking call that.
How did that fucking just happen on the last play of the game
and that he missed them and knocked his own guy down?
You have to be fucking kidding me.
I've literally seen it all.
I cannot fucking believe that just happened.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Exactly.
Case Keenum Oh my God.
I just saw it when the guy caught it.
I was like,
holy fuck.
Are they going to have time to kick a field goal?
Why won't anybody hug case keep them
look at the wide receiver.
Acted like he just did something to me.
He caught the ball,
but the that saints completely fucked up the act like he faked out that guy.
He,
wow.
Oh my God.
I don't know what the name of that St is,
but I got to fill in.
Everybody's going to know that name by tonight.
Holy Shit.
I cannot fucking believe that just happened.
That was another med.
When drew Pearson caught that fucking ball.
The Vikings are finally on the right side of one of these place.
Holy Shit.
Oh my God,
I cannot fucking believe.
I cannot fucking believe that just happened.
That was unbelievable.
Happy for Minnesota,
but Jesus Christ's sad for the saints.
What the fuck now?
How if you're that guy in the saints that missed the guy completely,
didn't even put your fucking arms out and then took out another player.
How do you go into that locker room?
What do you say?
What the fuck do you say?
Oh my God.
What are the fucking odds?
I was going to be watching this game the entire time.
Oh Jesus.
Now the rest got look reviewing the score.
It's a,
he didn't step out of bounds.
Don't take this away from football fans.
Don't take this away.
What did he do?
He just put his head down.
That's like some pop Warner shit.
Oh my God.
Ruling a field is confirmed.
Yeah,
the ref taken a lot of time here.
He never gets cheered.
We must kick the field goal.
I just shut it off.
I cannot wait a minute.
I've got to leave it on.
What if they fucking block it and score score.
Fucking touchdown.
Right?
I got to leave that on.
I can't,
I don't believe what I just saw.
I cannot fucking believe that.
How many times have I said that?
That was fucking unbelievable.
How do I follow this up with questions?
I just did all of that.
Now my next question,
do you miss the Prius?
I swear to God.
That's the question.
MMM.
Oh No,
they're going to clear the field.
Yeah,
we have to fucking kick the extra point.
The saints are gone.
Now they've got to come out of the locker room.
Um,
can you imagine if the gouge is fuck that play up,
block this extra point and ran it back for a touchdown.
That would be like watching a tosh point.
Oh.
Like you know when he has the people be able to do the redemptions without
needing tosh point.
Oh,
it'd be a self contained episode.
Um,
alright.
Hang on a second.
Let me fucking get my password in here.
Let me read this Prius thing while we're waiting.
Ah,
okay.
Do you miss the Prius?
What up Billy Buick?
I actually love a Buick back in the day.
I love Buicks.
You know when,
when a Cadillac was a Cadillac and Buick was like,
you know,
you weren't quite a Cadillac guy.
I wonder if this would have put them at least in field goal range,
the worst fucking attempt ever at a fucking,
the fact that that guy is a safety.
Oh my God,
I don't fight.
I just,
I know I've seen a lot of shit.
I seen a lot of shit.
What the fuck anyways.
Do you?
Hmm.
I know you're thrifty for years while driving your Prius built.
I was wondering if you still like driving a nicer vehicle,
a regret spending the money.
I'm in the recovery from buying new vehicles.
I wasted money for years on new cars and never really got any satisfaction from
it.
The past three years I've been driving a 2007 Honda accord.
Awesome.
And surprisingly,
I'm pretty happy with it.
Yeah,
dude,
once you get it paid off,
it's a shit.
I still have to fight the urge to buy a new ride often anyways.
Happy New Year from down in Alabama.
Um,
uh,
no,
cause I didn't buy a nice car until I could afford one.
Yeah.
Uh,
that's a mistake.
A lot of people do,
you know that trying to get some lady's attention or whatever the fuck it is or
they just love cars so much.
Like if you're really,
really a car guy,
understand like along the way you're going to have like nice cars.
But I was always about paying off my house and getting the bankers off my uh,
back.
I was into that shit.
This is what's fucked up is the saints right now.
They have a chance,
very small chance,
but they have a chance don't they,
to block the extra point and return it for a touchdown.
Can't that fucking happen?
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
I was always,
I was always way into no debt or working my way towards having no debt.
Like,
um,
I,
I just,
I can't stress that enough to young people,
but when you get like a credit card and all that shit,
it's just like be,
be really careful with those things and you can't like,
um,
oh,
this is smart.
They're just going to go for a 2.0 version.
It just down the ball.
So that can't happen.
There you go.
That's smart.
My dumb ass.
That's why I don't coach on any level.
Um,
anyways.
The um,
yeah,
I was,
I just was always in delight,
just not being in debt,
you know,
it just absolutely paralyzes you and it affects your ability to go after what
you want to go after.
I've told this story before,
like I kept a day job until I moved to New York the first three and a half
years.
I was a comedian probably the last year.
Well,
actually it's not true cause I was still living at home with my parents.
I could have basically,
um,
okay,
you know,
said,
hey,
can you help support me with my dream?
And I could have just been sitting around the house,
so just making comedy money.
But I continued to work and before I moved down in New York,
I paid off everything.
MMM.
I paid off my student loans.
I paid off my car,
which died right before I went to New York.
And I saved up a chunk of money and I just moved down to New York.
And,
uh,
I was never a ramen noodle guy,
but I definitely ate a lot of fucking rig Etonians Spaghetti and shit.
MMM.
And I just did that.
So,
um,
when I finally got it,
when I finally bought myself a nice car,
I could afford it and felt like I earned it.
And um,
yeah,
I loved it.
But I also love the Prius.
The Prius is a fucking great car,
you know,
cheapest shit to fucking own.
It's never a problem.
You Park it whatever you want.
No one's trying to steal a fucking Prius.
You know,
I always joked like,
you don't want,
mine was like eight or nine years old.
I literally could leave that thing on with the door open in the middle of a
fucking,
you know,
riot and no one would take it.
Like,
you know,
whenever they do the trap car,
I tried to get people to steal that car.
They,
they've never,
I will be willing to bet they never did that with the fucking Prius.
Now I want to know how many of those Viking fan stuck around.
You know,
some people left,
you know that they fucking left and as they were winding down the fucking
stairs,
they just start every going,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Then they had to fucking run their fat asses back up there.
Congratulations to the vikings.
Holy Shit.
The Vikings did not win that game.
That was a the biggest fuck up I have seen
in a long goddamn time.
Ah,
drew Brees and once again drew Brees to silent assassin.
Nobody knows how good that guy is and now he's not going to get to prove it in
the NFC championship game.
Potentially try to win a super bowl tragedy.
All right.
Bulletproof glass bullshit.
A dear Billy dad bought,
you know,
that hurts.
I was listening to your podcast a while back where you read someone's email
concerning owning a store with a bulletproof glass where his grandfather was
almost killed and he was outraged at the mandate and claimed the person pushing
the bill said,
bulletproof windows are racist.
I just wanted to point out that it was bullshit.
Most people in this country who get outraged over things,
they're oftentimes just misinformed.
And because we live in a consumer culture where the customer is always right.
No,
they're not.
Yeah,
that's old school.
The customer is not right.
The customer can go fuck themselves and talk to a fucking robot on the phone.
If you're bleeding to death,
press to the mindset has transitioned to politicians saying the citizens are
hardworking,
honest,
honorable Americans rather than saying the truth.
Most citizens are ignorant and titled Tribal,
both tribal mouth breathers.
Sir,
I don't know at what point in political history,
politicians were saying that.
They never said that either.
So you're kind of speaking in hyperbole,
I believe as the expression.
Uh,
but I understand what you're saying.
Um,
you're trying to build up your point.
This is the bill that was proposed regarding bulletproof windows.
Um,
I am not fucking reading all of that.
Uh,
it's regarding restaurants and no other places of business.
So that person that wrote you in fear of having his bulletproof glass band is
basically an outrage over nothing.
Oh,
in outraged,
you know,
in outrage,
you mean?
No.
D It doesn't even affect him or his grandfather.
Well,
that's good.
It was never called racist.
We want to make sure that there isn't this sort of indignity,
in my opinion,
to serving food through a Plexiglas only in certain neighborhoods.
What?
That doesn't make sense.
Yeah.
Well who are you to say it's indignant?
Okay.
Ah,
you know what?
That's,
that's sneaky writing right there.
You're going to get offended for people.
I don't understand what's going on here.
I don't know.
It was never called racist.
We want to make sure that there isn't this sort of indignity,
in my opinion,
to serving food through a Plexiglas only in a certain neighborhoods.
Well,
whenever I was doing gigs and bad neighborhoods and they had that fall,
can bulletproof glass,
I always looked at it.
Okay,
heads up.
Keep your head on a swivel.
I appreciated it being there.
I didn't feel like fucking,
I dunno what you tried to do here,
but I,
I am in favor of hurting some people's feelings.
If it keeps people who want to just have the honest job of working at a
restaurant alive.
Um,
I would be in favor of it and I don't think it's Plexiglas.
Is it?
Plexiglass stops a bullet.
I don't fuck it though.
Um,
that's from Philadelphia.
Council woman,
Cindy Bass.
All right,
let's look up Cindy Baz.
Cindy can be your friend.
Three 10.
She's your fucking council man.
Why does it always take me to fucking Wikipedia now?
What the fuck?
Where are we Cindy bass images.
Okay.
Cindy Bass appears to be African American.
All right,
so this person was saying that she was being racist.
Now,
according to some people,
it's impossible for a black person to be ready.
I don't even know what the fuck is going on right now.
I don't know.
All I know is if I worked in a Goddamn restaurant and somebody nearby had shot
someone in a restaurant to the point that somebody felt that they needed to be
some fucking glass up there,
uh,
I would want it.
But who the fuck am I to say what people need in their,
in their neighborhood?
Well,
how the fuck did I get signed out of that thing?
Hey,
when it's signed you out as it goes,
do you want to make a report?
No,
I don't have time for that shit.
Like,
who has time to do that?
I'm always trying to do poor kids.
Oh,
so no showing dope.
Um,
it was never called cable.
While I still don't agree that any type of business should be mandated to remove
a type of security for whatever it was.
Websites like steadfast and loyal.com that wrote bulletproof glass is now racist
in their title.
However,
you know what,
I actually understand what you're saying here.
Cause that type of shit happens to comedians all the time where they just,
you know,
they float something out there,
Huffington Post,
and then they try to get you in trouble or make it more sensationalized so they
can get views.
Uh,
however,
in the body of the article,
they admitted that the council woman never used those words.
But of course most people read beyond this article.
Yeah,
see,
I mean that's the Internet.
There's really no,
uh,
there's no libel.
There's no,
there's none.
I cannot fucking,
I got to hear what this guy said.
God cared.
God cared that this Guy Yeps God cared.
The other guy had too much devil in him and Debbie other that the safety on the
saints.
He prayed to the devil.
That's what happened.
And the devil misled to tackle air to tackle his own fucking teammate.
Uh,
I know you're a comedian and not some fucking political correspondents,
so it's not like I'm trying to hold you up to some Barbara Walters type of
standard,
but I know some people in your audience forget that and believe everything they
read in everything they hear that feeds into what they already believe.
Like you said,
I am right.com.
Yeah,
well,
dude,
nobody's coming to this fucking website to become informed.
Okay.
Um,
don't put that on me.
Okay.
I did not pursue that,
which is why I became a comedian.
All right.
I tried to Siri,
the serious world.
It didn't fucking work out for me.
I failed miserably.
Okay.
Failed my wife.
All right,
dear Billy buddy guy,
my wife and I had been married for a year and a half.
We both have a child from prior relationships and a seventh month old daughter
together.
She's an angel by the way.
Of course she is.
She is Latina and I only bring that up because she fits all the fiery
stereotypes,
both good and bad.
She completes my life with this.
Although arguments can get very difficult.
Okay.
Dude,
I thought you were talking about your seven month old.
It's fucking hilarious.
You went right into that.
I thought you're good.
You already have an arguments with a seven month old and she's fiery,
blah blah blah blah.
Fucking talking.
Jibberish okay.
Your wife.
Okay.
She's Latina and I only bring that up because she fits all these stereotypes.
She completes my life.
Oh Blah blah blah.
I have some of the same temper issues that you use to describe yourself and your
bit about kneeling on the ball when I'm right is paid off huge.
Uh,
so thank you for that.
Yeah,
I wish I should probably rewatch that bit cause I have not been doing that
lately.
I've been Aaron it out.
Anyway to cut to the chase we decided together to fight for primary custody of
my son.
The case is very complicated,
but for the sake of everyone listening,
I'll summarize it with his few details as possible.
In family court before peering in front of a judge,
there is a conference where immediate mediator tries everything they can to make
sure you can come to an agreement and avoid a judge.
Deciding,
my wife and I had a plan going in to not cut a deal with my ex at the conference
and hold out for a judge to rule on custody.
However,
I had no idea the level of pressure that they'd be able to on me and I buckled
under it and made a deal for the next year.
Then I had to go home and explain to my wife that I had failed our plan.
I don't know if you've ever completely disappointed your woman,
but this is the worst feeling in the world.
Well,
wait a minute.
She's going to judge you because they probably used your love of your own kid
right against you.
Anyways,
and as you can imagine over the past day or so,
she's cutting me into me.
It's just about every opportunity for all the little failures and I can see it
right in and arise that are man had a moment of weakness and didn't come through
in the clutch.
Worse is that she absolutely hates my ex and feels like I let her get the better
of me.
US.
Yeah.
You know,
kind of feeling.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Oh Geez.
You're in the middle of that.
You're in the middle of the two ladies.
You have ever disappointed you a woman with a grand fuck up about every three
days.
I guess a good boxing analogy is that my hands are down and I don't know how
long to let her continue jabbing at me until I put them back up.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Uh,
I wouldn't take another ounce of shit from her.
Yeah.
I,
you need to sit down and talk to her and be like,
wait a minute.
I'm trying to get my kid back.
I'm going back with all of this emotion.
Wait,
let me make sure this is,
you decided together to get primary custody of your son.
Now,
who's idea was that?
Was that totally yours or was the hatred your wife has of your ex wife played
into the thing?
Um,
I,
I don't know,
Dude.
I don't know what's going on,
but it sounds when it went into my head.
Okay,
now no notice.
No.
That everything that you say is now perverted cause went into my brain.
As I say,
once you say something,
it's not what you said anymore.
It's cut with the other person's experiences.
It's like drugs that have been stepped on.
What you said was pure cocaine.
Now it's in my head and this all this [inaudible] fucking laxatives getting
fucking put in it.
Um,
all I hear is that your wife,
uh,
your current wife resents your previous fucking wife and uh,
she's doing that woman thing where they don't solve things with their fists.
They try to fucking make,
they just do that thing where they tried to make the other woman as miserable as
they possibly can and she knows probably how much it would break.
Yeah.
Your ex,
why is hard to lose a primary custody of your son?
And she really wanted to do that to her because that would make her feel better
and more secure in your relationship.
I don't fucking know.
I have no idea to this too many fucking variables here.
But um,
I wouldn't take it out of shit if I had a son from a previous marriage and you
know,
I was trying to do what you were doing and then I caved under that pressure.
My wife would understand it and if she ever gave me shit,
I would be stunned and then I would fucking read her the riot act and I would go
out to a bar and have a couple of cold ones there.
That's what I do.
Okay.
Now I get into a lot of arguments in my relationships.
We probably don't want to listen to me.
I have no professional background.
Okay.
I'm the type of man that once that already types out,
dude,
I called it with 25 seconds left in fucking jinx is the saints.
Maybe it was my fault.
Um,
all right.
I don't know what the fuck that was.
But you can't say it wasn't compelling.
If you're a football fan,
everybody else,
I apologize to go fuck yourselves and I'll check in on Ya on Thursday.